how's the gum razz my name is check the
oh thank you and welcome to flappy bird
knock-offs
I see Bros may know you can't play
flappy bird anymore unless you didn't
delete it but there's a ton of knockoffs
of flappy flappy bird and I thought
we're gonna play the one that was
suggested the most first
it's called iron pants but before we
begin I'm gonna have some lemon juice
I need my lemon juice for this [ __ ] man
lemons technically this game is free and
it doesn't have any apps I don't see how
it's I can hurt anyone that it exists
still the fact that games like physics
is it's just like hey I'll [ __ ] thing
yeah all of them this [ __ ] tell me to
hold holding does not work why oh okay
okay I got it okay I don't got it at all
just like in real life it's almost hard
getting in the first window haha six
joke come on I gotta beat my flappy bird
high score of like 50 million this is
really hard man okay [ __ ] me [ __ ] you
[ __ ] my new shoes don't do it they're
new come on easy this game's easy
this game is easier than your mom owns
on some tequila [ __ ] sake
[Music]
the way it looks like oh no you breaking
breaking breaking pick it how does that
even touch yeah now you're just touching
my ass I like it a little bit you can do
it what you want if you see me on the
streets feel free to touch my ass
anytime you like just sayin how did we
get to this conversation let's get to
ten baby let's get you [ __ ] dad
[Music]
that's my victory dance
all right now 220 that's never ever
happening
I just think the pay's in the [ __ ]
flappy bird is so slow that it just
pisses you off even more I guess but the
guy isn't even [ __ ] moving you're
just like come on stop flapping and more
flying you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] then I
just like starting with our name of RIT
14 holy [ __ ] okay 20 20 20 20 20 20 20
mine do any mod that how am I supposed
to go off when it's I hold up I thought
it was gonna make 20 we're gonna [ __ ]
make 20 man [ __ ] you this is gonna
become like a new genre of gaming like
flappy games okay okay
2000 love it Oh does the game get harder
or is it my penis
shut up pills seriously 15 [ __ ] 16
[ __ ] mini job are you enjoying this
oh that's great you know I wish you
should go out someday
just you and me mad woman thing entity
dolphin you're a dolphin right hey I'm
not racist man whom will be I'm sick
that amends it up and Yosuke fun for
Shuggie okay I'm just not gonna talk
[Music]
what an even [ __ ] 24 lucky number
okay what's next yes dog dumpy doggy its
oh you have lights oh yeah then the game
was buggers okay what's with the [ __ ]
lag holy [ __ ]
why is it upside down for you too lazy
to carry I can't even keep up please
much over of course of course you know
what [ __ ] [ __ ] that one I'm Adam and I
don't even all right there's a couple
more on the PC that I want to check out
so there's the flappy flap mo which is
an MMO of flappy bird because of [ __ ]
chords that has to exist
I can change theme apparently I can be
this up sperms okay of course okay so so
you can see other people [ __ ] dying
and [ __ ] this is just like real life
great now I can just feel bad how much
better everyone else is at this [ __ ]
game okay it's funny how [ __ ] many
dies on the first one this is this game
in a nutshell man I'm gonna beat you you
[ __ ]
yes no I am the Golan's Fadem a [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] booty what hell are you
doing what is you inning that's [ __ ]
everyone knows poorly pie is the real
pudding pudding pie no alright well now
I I actually like that one that one's
pretty cool let's check out another one
another one is flappy bird alright here
we go okay oh god that's obnoxious [ __ ]
come on how's that 17 when did I get 17
I'd rather die than listen to this oh
gosh that was fun right
vocalist bird press space to flap whoa
oh my god
it's like I'm actually flying brother oh
yeah become the flappy bird they said
now come on alright well this is pretty
fun
I think I'm God what the [ __ ] is that
this is what I'm wasting my life with
okay well let's embrace it fantastic of
wrecking balls and select am I on nope
no more no [ __ ] more okay so this one
is probably the best one because [ __ ]
you that's why was flapping now [ __ ] I
don't even know what's going on anymore
I don't even know what's going on ain't
nobody get through this
ain't nobody guess in my flappy holes
that's enough flappy bird for probably
ever there's probably a ton of them that
I missed but I wanted to show at least
some of them but let me know which one
is your favorite so I hope you bros
enjoyed anyway leave a like if you did I
really appreciate it it helps me out a
lot and as always it's a breakfast for
you stay awesome bris love you
[Music]